hey youtubers is Charlie
since arrow is on break this week I
wanted to do a bonus flash video so this
is gonna be my top 5 flash films that I
want to see during season 1 of the show
we also got a good look at grant
gustin's full flash costume so we should
probably talk about that first if you're
finding me for the first time I do arrow
and flash videos every week along with
bonus Q&A videos be sure to subscribe to
get everything we're still kind of in
the middle of arrow season 2 so we still
have several episodes left and they're
gonna be filming the flash palette for
the next couple of weeks so let's talk
about grant gustin's flash costume as
expected it looks a little bit more like
a tech suit than straight-up fabric like
Stephen Amell s arrow suit the same
person actually made both of those the
pictures we've seen from the set don't
include any special effects but I think
that once they edit the footage they'll
tweak the colors just a little bit and
add some highlights if you remember when
they debuted Stephen amell's costume it
was a much more muted green color than
the bright green from the comic books
they tuned the color down mostly for
practical reasons one it's supposed to
help hide his identity - it can't be too
distracting on camera and three bright
colors look a little bit silly in real
life they even muted the blue and red of
Superman's costume during Man of Steel
so that's why the red we're seeing is so
dark compared to the comic book version
I think it's pretty cool I'm glad that
they didn't go crazy with the yellow
lightning bolt highlights it would have
been way too distracting their goal is
to draw as much attention to cranked
gustin's face for viewers like you and
me well at the same time hiding his
identity from the other characters like
whenever Stephen Amell is on screen
you're staring at his face but for some
reason detective Lance never questions
this identity here is a quick history of
the different flash costumes over the
years starting with Jay Garrick who may
or may not be in the flash pilot played
by John Wesley Shipp Jay Garrick's
costume has largely remained unchanged
over the years when DC rebooted
everything with new 52
they also rebooted Jay Garrick in the
earth-2 series with this alternate
costume so currently this is what he
looks like but if he does appear in the
pilot it's possible that they'll stick
with the Golden Age version of the
costume Barry Allen's costume has also
largely stayed the same since the
character debuted during new 52 they did
add some more texture to the flash
symbol on his chest as you can see grant
gustin's version is much less spandexy
looking which is a good thing
we don't know where he'll get the
costume yet either from the ring or it
will be like Stephen Amell s costume and
he'll physically have to climb into it
like a regular pair of pants
then there's the Wally West costume it
as well has largely remained unchanged
over the years the big difference from
the Barry Allen costume is that the nose
is covered the new 52 version of Wally
West the curb version is actually
debuting finally in flash annual number
three that's coming in April 30th next
month so he'll actually be reintroduced
to the DC Universe just like all the
other characters after flashpoint this
is what the brand new version of the
costume is going to look like imagine it
in red though this is just a variant he
actually kind of looks like the black
flash which I'll talk about in a little
bit but nitrogen though let me know what
do you think about grant gustin's
costume and how do you think he's going
to get it how do you think it's gonna
work so now let's have some fun and talk
about the villains they've already cast
the antagonist for the pilot which is
you know Edward Thawne who's gonna be
the reverse-flash played by Rick cuz net
and danielle Panabaker who's gonna be
killer frost now if everything goes
according to plan then just like arrow
they'll get 23 episodes for season 1
which is a lot so they're gonna have to
dip into the comics to pull some more
villains out remember Barry Allen and
even Edward Thawne are gonna be working
at a police station on the show so it's
entirely likely that they'll be hunting
down and arresting villains every week
but here we go number 5 heatwave
like some of my other picks he's one of
the core rogues the most frequent
repairing group of villains the flash
runs into heatwave as a child became
obsessed with fire and is essentially a
pyromaniac the other rogues like Captain
Cold inspired him to channel his
obsession into a new identity which is
when he took on the heatwave persona
post new 52 he was disfigured when he
and the other Rogues gained their
superpowers and now he can generate fire
naturally from his body it's likely on
the show if they use the character that
they'll use that particle accelerator
explosion to give all the Rogues
including heatwave their metahuman
abilities but it's also possible that
they could do it old-school and have
them use the heat guns like during flash
rebirth they did imply that we would be
seeing more super-powered people on the
show but they didn't say if everyone's
gonna have powers at the beginning
whenever the show starts or if they're
gonna develop them over time number 4
the axel walker trickster he's the
current version of the character in the
comics he was a normal person that took
the name from the original trickster
every
right now in the comics he's already had
his arm torn off by a gorilla grodd and
it's kind of been exiled from the roads
he doesn't have any superpowers and is
really more of a nuisance to the flash
thinking exploding yo-yos but he does
have a pair of shoes that allow him to
fly for periods of time I can only
imagine how the show will deal with that
though
number three weather wizard like the
other Rogues he also gained his
superpowers during the new 52 reboot the
name explains everything
but because of the way his powers work
the more he uses them to control weather
the more depressed he gets which is kind
of funny as part of the comics reboot he
goes after dr. Elias who the Rogues
blamed for the accident that gave them
superpowers so the TV show is just
substituting the character Tom Cavanagh
is playing Harrison wells for that dr.
Elias character in the comics Harrison
wells is the person on the show that
they're gonna blame for the particle
accelerator explosion so any Rogues on
the show will probably try to get
revenge on him and Grant Gustin want to
step in to stop them number two Captain
Cold
one of the interesting things about the
character is that even though he is a
supervillain he has a moral code he's
usually the one you hear quoting the
phrase rule number one of the Rogues you
never kill a flash he does have a sister
that he cares about so of all the second
tier flash villains he's one of the most
complex in my opinion there can be no
flash show without Captain Cold so of
all the people on my list he's the most
likely we'll see during season one
during the current version of the comics
he even ends up working with Barry Allen
so it's likely on the show that he could
end up working with Grant Gustin for
short periods of time you know like in
the way that Oliver and Diggle are
working with the Suicide Squad on arrow
and my number one flash film that I
really want to see during season one the
black flash he's the physical embodiment
of death so even though he's a character
he's kind of more of an abstract idea in
the comics the most recent version of
the character is just a negative aspect
to the Speed Force essentially it means
like his role in the story is to balance
the scales on a physics level there's a
positive aspect of the Speed Force that
Barry Allen and all the other flashes
get their power from including professor
zoom and then there's the negative
aspect of the Speed Force which the
black flash draws his power from as you
saw earlier in the video they're
bringing Wally West back in the comics
next month and it looks like he's a
version of the black flash so I'm sure
the story will have something to do with
that
so now it's your turn let me know which
villains do you once eat during season
one of the flash they're gonna save some
of the bigger ones for season two like
gorilla grodd I'm sure but that means
that they're just gonna bring out some
of the smaller rogues first so next week
arrows back with the Suicide Squad
episode be sure to subscribe to get my
video we're gonna get to see Harley
Quinn for the first time on arrow it's
gonna be amazing she's actually being
played by Caitlin Alexa you can click
here to learn all about that in my
latest arrow video and you can click
here to learn more about the flash
season 1 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight high fives
you